we are making a watch list and checking
it twice this Christmas there are plenty
of new holiday movies you have to catch
from sequels to Classics new musicals
and even Christmas horror movies with
cult Killers yeah this is going to be
one fun Christmas if you watch the right
movies that is start your holiday movie
marathon with a trip down candye Lane
Candy Cane Lane Stars none other than
Eddie Murphy as Chris a Christmas effici
a Who will stop at nothing to win his
neighborhood Christmas decorating
contest this year so he does what any
true Christmas lover would do he makes a
deal with an elf played by Jillian Bell
and let's just say it doesn't go exactly
as planned honestly it's like you're
signing your life away away the film
which also Stars Tracy Ellis Ross Nick
Offerman Robin thei and more will start
streaming on Amazon Prime video on
December 1st